عززت اسرائيل سيطرتها على ما يسمى غلاف
غزه لاهداف
استراتيجيه بوصفه منطقه عزله على طول
الحدود البريه مع القطاع ولقطع امكانيه
الاتصال الجغرافي بين القطاع والضفه
الغربيه ومن ثم تجهض اي فرصه لاقامه دوله
فلسطينيه وتستخدم اسرائيل هذا الواقع لفرض
تغيير ديموغرافي ولتحقيق ذلك تقدم مغريات
واسعه لسكان المستوطنات
وغالبيتهم من اليهود الشرقيين بوصفهم
حاجزا جغرافيا
وديموغرافي فمما يتشكل ما يسمى غلاف غزه
عقب الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من القطاع عام
2005 ابقت اسرائيل وعززت عشرات المستوطنات
منها ما هو ملاصق للقطاع والتي يطلق عليها
الان غلاف غزه يبلغ عددها نحو 50 مستوطنه
وتمتد على مسافه 40 كيلومترا تقريبا يدير
هذه المستوطنات ما يسمى بالمجالس
الاقليميه التي تتبع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وهي
ثلاثه مجلس اشكول ويمتد على مساحه
380 كيومت مربعا يسكنه اكثر من 13 الف مص
خوط يعيشون في
مستوطنه مجلس اشكلون ويمتد على مساحه
175 كت مربعا يعيش فيه حوالي 17 ال مستوطن
في اربع
مستوطنات ومجلس شاعر هناف ويمتد على مساحه
18 كت
مربعا على 11 مستوطنه ويعيش فيها
اكثر من
مستوطن